hey everybody hope you're doing well and
welcome back to park attacks today I'm
gonna try and tackle honey Hills which
is the second scenario that I've made
for the game so I was really still
trying to find my ground in terms of
what these scenarios would be like so
yeah it's quite large and the map isn't
too difficult to work with but this also
gives some good opportunities to build
stuff I think now the goals aren't too
difficult there's a go of getting 400
guests into the park having no loan
debts which we don't start off with any
loans so that should be fine an
operating profit of $2,000 a month which
is maybe going to be the most difficult
part of this and an overall Pyke rating
of 75 percent so yeah altogether it's
not a very difficult scenario we start
off with some hilly land here really the
idea behind this scenario was to try and
get used to more difficult to work with
terrain so there are some small flat
sections especially around this area
where you can build like some main kind
of area but aside from that it's all
very hilly so yeah the challenge here
will mostly just be the terrain and we
start off with this coaster called
bumble bee which is a bit ironic because
bumble bee doesn't make any honey or
well not really honey honey it makes it
kind of honey apparently but yeah it's a
core sounding name okay it doesn't have
to be entirely scientifically accurate
anyway that's all I'm gonna start
building and we'll see where it goes all
right so something I just noticed and I
want to point out before I forget to do
it in any other video is that these
time-lapse sections are much more bright
and saturated than the real-time
sections and I don't know why but for
some reason OBS is what I use to record
my real-time section and OBS just makes
the whole game look a little bit less
bright
and record my time-lapses with fraps I
was originally hoping to do all of it
with dxtory but or dxtory I don't know
exactly how to pronounce it but for some
reason I didn't want to cooperate with
architects so I'm using fraps instead
which as much criticism as it tends to
get at least it actually shows how
saturated and bright spark text is
because OBS just kind of tones down
everything so what you see during the
time lapses is actually a more accurate
representation of what I see when I'm
working on the game I was thinking about
just manually upping the brightness and
contrasts and editing but I don't know
how I feel about that idea but in any
case it's something that I've noticed
and if it's something that for some
reason you notice this well well here
you go
this is white anyway let's move into
what I'm actually doing here I have had
quite a few requests to build more log
flumes
and I think that's a pretty good idea so
I'm starting off with the log flume on
this scenario especially because this is
quite a terrain heavy scenario that's
really the only challenge that we got
here and for me I like a good log flume
but I love a good terrain conforming log
flume especially when they're themed and
they've got some interaction with other
rides this is what log flumes are best
on I think especially given that you'll
be spending most of the ride either on a
slow conveyor belt lift Hill or on some
sort of straights part of the track
between two drops you mostly just want
to have interesting scenery around the
ride and some kind of interaction with
the rest of the park so I think maps
with terraforming like this are perfect
for log flumes in combination with other
rides as well so for this whole area I
was trying to plan everything ahead of
time and make sure that I had some
opportunities to have that log flume
interact with the rollercoaster
and with the path work and have the path
work interact with both of those as well
just kind of make everything very mixed
which takes quite a bit of not per se
planning but it takes quite a bit of
building stuff and then trying to
visualize how it would look with
everything in place
and then kind of using a trial and error
method in that sense to figure out what
you want the whole area to be shaped
like so I started off with the log flume
because this is probably the most well
not very flexible right because it
involves a lot of straight pieces and
you can't really put the drops in many
places and after this I think the most
important thing to add is the roller
coaster and for this I'm choosing to go
with the regular steel coaster
but kind of make it a family coaster
without inversions and mostly just large
sweeping turns and some large hills very
similar to liseberg Bannen in leesburg
in Sweden which is a swatch coke coaster
and one of my favorite swatch Cup
coasters is it's really not that intense
it's really not that exciting but it
really follows the terrain of the park
and it has a lot of interaction with
different rides and this is such a cool
amazing relaxing family coaster
definitely one of my favorite family
coasters out there and probably the
crowning masterpiece of swatch Cup at
least supposedly I've heard from some
people that leesburg Bonin is Anton's
watch cops own favorite coaster that
he's worked on although I'm not entirely
sure in that one it also has a slightly
different track than many of the others
watch cup coasters we're usually swatch
cup coasters have their spline or their
spine just below the track ties this one
has the spine in the middle of the track
ties so it's kind of a really strange
track type where you've got three tubes
right next to each other the ones on the
outside being the rails and the one in
the middle being the spine there just to
make the whole track stronger but yeah
it's really cool coaster I really love
it and honestly one of the highlights at
Liseberg I think but yeah that was my
inspiration I was I am really trying to
stretch out how much I'm talking about
this coaster because I struggled quite a
bit with the layout here just because
space is so limited and I
really wanted to curves that go into two
different directions because that looks
really nice but it was really difficult
to fit anything in and also get a decent
speed going so at this point for
instance I've got these hills going over
the middle of the track here going over
the log flume but at that point it was
really just kind of creeping over these
hills at a very slow speed so I wasn't
too happy with that so eventually I
ended up removing this idea as well just
making the little it's a bit taller
really the thing that made all of this
difficult is the log flume which I have
to get over somehow well at the same
time I also want to make this coast a
varied terrain conforming and I never
want it to be you know two up high from
wherever the ground is at any points I
think actually if this were a scenario
where you're not allowed to build above
tree Heights this coaster would make
that well I think yeah I think you'd be
able to build this so yeah I'm trying to
follow the terrain as much as I can you
eventually I ended up with this layouts
with the coaster just barely making it
over the log flume and finally coming
back to go into the middle of this area
which is all gonna be paths and scenery
and kind of drop down below a bridge for
pedestrians which i think is really cool
interactions with the path that'll make
the the whole area look more interesting
for people not on the coaster but it
should also make the coaster itself more
interesting with a head chopper diving
underneath the path so yeah that's
always quite good I did end up removing
that helix there at the end as you can
see just because I couldn't figure out a
way to fit a path leading to this
station there the station is kind of in
a completely different area which to be
honest I'm not entirely sure how I feel
about that but I also wanted to draw
this lake into the rest of the park so
at least having the station here forces
people to go down to this lake and see
this other view because I I had to
manually make this lake because it
didn't come with a scenario and I
thought it would look quite good so I'm
trying to make the most of it as well
and actually use it to incorporate it
into the scenery and into the general
landscape of the park so yeah that is
basically how this works but there's not
going to be anything else here because
it's just really limited in terms of
space it's really just going to be the
station of the coaster but altogether I
think there's some decent interaction
between the coaster and the log flume
and now that the two big rides are in
place now is when I actually figure out
most of the rest of the path and scenery
work because you can just generally kind
of fit that in between different areas
so yeah I did consider however where I
wanted to place buildings so some of
those areas that you can see left open
between the paths will be buildings and
flat rights and such now what I think is
also quite interesting here is this area
just above the curve of the log flume I
always wanted to have the log flume
covered here and have it go into a
little indoor area the only problem is
that the log flume is kind of sunken
into the water here which is quite cool
I really loved that impact X you're able
to build log flumes into the ground and
into the water that's something that I
wish we had in rollercoaster tycoon
because you can really just I think you
can get it up to a quarter below the
height of the grid and it won't form a
tunnel or anything you know really just
make it trench of water inside the lake
or inside the ground wherever you're
building the log flume so that's super
cool the only thing is that you're not
able to build paths a half step above
that because there's just barely not
enough clearance so I couldn't build the
path about above the curve of the log
flume with actual path so I took some
roof pieces and raised them up a little
bit to make the clearance right and
basically made a little seating area
that people cannot actually go to
because it's all just scenery so
yeah it's just for show but I thought it
would look much better than having
actual parts there and having to raise
them even more because then it would
just sort of cut off this area from the
rest of the parts in terms of aesthetics
so yeah I'd rather have design over
function in this case that's that there
should be plenty of seating areas on the
actual paths as well so it should be
more or less fine now something that I
don't always do but especially for this
scenario I think would look quite good
is adding some scenery to some of these
cliffs so you always get these cliffs
when you're chipping away at the
terraforming and you leave some straight
walls and the game automatically gives
it a kind of earthen texture but for
this scenario I thought that wouldn't
really fit so for some of the cliffs
I've gone for a stucco wooden beam
texture and then for some of the other
ones it's really just wooden walls
especially on the cue line there which
honestly I think it looks a little bit
better than just having the regular
in-game cliff textures it's a little bit
more work but I do like it especially
given the rustic kind of look of this
scenario and yeah as for scenery I'm
trying to fit this in with the scenery
that's already in the park even if it's
very basic again this is one of the
first scenarios that I made and I have
to say I also try to keep the scenery
that I added in the scenarios as
minimalistic as possible so that anybody
could easily pick up the parks and try
to continue in a similar style so yeah I
wouldn't personally want to over theme
the scenarios because you want to leave
a lot of that up to the player I think a
scenario should really only give the
player a basis to work with or some
inspiration to start off with but really
not more than that so yeah it's quite
basic but I'm keeping the generic theme
here and actually for my inspiration
this time I went back all the way to
catfish Cove which is a custom scenery
set that shyguy made for rollercoaster
tycoon 3 which is based on an actual
miniature theme park that he's made
and it's it's just a really simple set
of walls and roofs and they're all
different shades of brown it's really
quite simple but it it very much fits
the style of this scenario I think so
that's what I'm mostly going for it's a
bit similar to Alpine but there's a lot
more wooden textures less timber work
and just an overall I guess more of an
American sort of style to it maybe your
Vermont or something like that
not entirely sure but given that shy guy
is an American even though the catfish
Cove was next to the alpine area in his
Park if I remember correctly it
definitely feels like it should be an
American kind of style as opposed to
European Alpine which is quite different
and yeah that's also the station
building very much follows the same it
really kind of looks like a building
that was made with the Gantt fish Cove
said in rollercoaster [ __ ] three I don't
know how much is available on the
internet about this but if you go ahead
and compare it the brown colors really
fit the roof and the wall texture is
that the catfish Cove set had but yeah
I'm keeping everything quite minimal
except for very small details like the
timber work on some of the gables there
and just that overall shape for a
station I really like it's just I kind
of I don't know it's just a sort of
design that works every single time to
have one main stretch of building in the
same direction as the coaster track
where you put the cue and the exit path
underneath that and then somewhere
around the front of the station you just
put an extra elements that you know
points toward the entrance of the
station and it's just really well
balanced I like that whole way of
picking stations I think after a while
the further I get into these scenarios
you could probably notice that my
stations all start looking very similar
but I mean in real life stations also
very typically do this have just one
gabled roof in the same direction as the
coast of track is going and then some
kind of elements to mark where the front
is where
entrance of the station is where you
want to get in so yeah I think it works
well and it's always a very simple way
to build a decent station without having
to experiment too much or go out of your
comfort zone and moving on from here
I'm building a drop tower here which i
think is something that I just put there
because it's the smallest flat ride and
it fits just about anywhere you want it
to fit and really no other reason it's
just the best thing to fit in here we
don't have a lot of flat rights in this
scenario actually so that's something
that I might research but before I do
that I need to research the stalls
because if we only start out with a
vending machine for food and drinks and
that that's not going to do so that's
actually kind of a challenge about this
scenario you really need to research
right from the get-go and make sure you
get some stores because otherwise you
could get in trouble for that later on
I'm not sure to what extent guests can
satisfy themselves with the vending
machine but I mean it only sells soda or
pop whenever you want to say and chips
or crisps or whatever you want to say
there but you know that's not a very
healthy balanced diets so that's
something I should get into as well you
might have noticed also that I've had my
game on pause the whole time and that's
partly because you start off with so
much money in this scenario that I could
you know just let it be paused and still
keep building and until I run out of
money but also I'm trying to go for
those optional challenges again I'm not
sure how well it's gonna work but I
think it'll be nice to try it at least
so yeah I might keep the game passed
more often but I do have to say I prefer
playing with the game unpause just
seeing the park run and seeing guests
react to what you're building in real
time it's just so much more satisfying
than building everything in one go well
the game is posting and resuming it at
some point to try and get those
challenge goals not to mention that you
know you really don't need to get the
challenge goals per se so yeah I don't
know if I'm gonna keep doing this
but for
scenario it works out because you have a
lot of money at the start and I figured
might as well try now at this point I
did open up the park so I think it's
time to let it run for a while and see
how the park is doing and if we can
actually run a profit on this yeah so
basically I have loads of money
I'm almost reaching that two thousand
dollars a month go I actually had it for
one month although we might have to hold
it for a few months I I don't think it
should be too difficult to get there and
also my experience is reading is almost
75 percent and as you can see I'm also
getting closer than 400 guests that we
need to get into the park so yeah
altogether it doesn't seem like a very
difficult scenario so far but it's been
a lot of fun trying to fit all of the
scenery into this very difficult to work
with terrain there's not a lot of flat
space to work with so you really kind of
have to be creative there my next plans
are actually to build a ferris wheel
over here covering this path I think
that should be interesting and a good
way to actually get a good view from the
ferris wheel and also a flat ride over
here and if I really need to I could
build an inverted coaster because I
accidentally got that out of research
because I forgot to switch the research
to shops on time so they ended up
researching a coaster anyway but that
could be useful the inverted coaster is
always a lot of fun to build and very
good to drawing guests and earn extra
cash as well but yeah aside from that I
think we're doing quite fine I just got
a burger store so at last people can
actually eat something it's slightly
healthier than chips but yeah it's it's
still not the best thing so whatever its
theme park food when do theme parks
actually have good food so yeah all
together Park is doing quite well I
think it could actually yeah we should
do a quick POV of this coaster it
doesn't have super good stats but you
know it's just the family coasters so
considering what it is I think it works
quite well okay maybe I should add a
second or two to the block break timing
there but yeah it's just doing some
curves around this area nothing too
special I do want to put some more trees
in here is
that's one of the things that I still
wanted to do as well along with of
course the station which I haven't done
for this coaster I do
but yeah it's really coming together I
think and the way that everything
interacts with the park is definitely
the strongest point about this park
yeah it's also quite a short layout
because at this point it's already over
but it does end on the high notes I
think with that final drop actually
being the largest drop in the ride and I
think it also reaches the maximum speed
in this part but yeah that's it's I'm
gonna keep on building and try to get to
those objectives as soon as possible not
because I want to try and rush every
scenario but now that I can and I have
the opportunity to meet the challenge
goals I definitely want to go for it so
I want to start off by building this
station for the coaster and basically
get that out of the way and also in the
meantime I'm gonna let the game play not
like I'm doing right now but in a little
bit I'll unpause the game and try to let
people keep going to the park and see
how close to the goals I can actually
get because I did just check and it
turns out that this is one of the
scenarios where you have to hold the
goals for two months in order to
actually finish the scenario which is
actually kind of helpful in my case
because I'm trying to avoid accidentally
reaching all of the objectives while I'm
in the middle of the time-lapse and I
don't even realize that I just finished
the map which is kind of anticlimactic
but with cases like this it gives you a
very neat progress bar to let you know
just how far into the scenario you are
and whether you're reaching the
objective so yeah that's pretty cool
also what's interesting about this
building I think is these walls which
are kind of an object that I don't use
too many times for wooden buildings but
the thing about this wall is with all of
the vertical kind of textures on it the
thing is I'm still not sure whether it's
supposed to be a steel wall or a wooden
one or what exactly what kind of
material it is but in a sense this is
something that I really like about Park
attacks the way that a lot of the
textures are really minimalistic and
context dependent allow you to basically
use them in any kind of context that you
want and to substitute for any kind of
material that you want so and in this
case very similar to the rest of the
park I would imagine this to be yellow
painted planks for the walls but very
these things usually kind of work as is
some sort of gray metal warm so it
really just depends on the kind of color
that you give them and what the overall
scenery and and theme if the surrounding
area is what kind of texture what kind
of feeling the walls will have so just
something about Park tech that allows
you to basically use any pieces any
material or anything ever because
everything is so minimalistic in design
and I quite like that but yeah that's
basically the station very simple
building very similar also to the
station of the log flume although it's
it is definitely a bit different it has
some of those more gentle roofs as well
and just an overall slightly different
shape but I think the composition of it
is pretty similar now at this point I
was actually kind of having trouble I
really underestimated the scenario at
this point because I didn't have too
much stuff and I was just getting
vandalism and litter all over the park
and that dramatically decreased my park
rating and then people left the park and
I was making enough profit anymore and
the things just kind of turned into a
big avalanche of trouble from there but
eventually I fixed all of those issues
and things started going well again but
yeah I'm really always trying to pay
attention to vandalism and things like
that in your part because I tend to
forget about the actual management when
I'm building stuff and yeah you can
really fill a scenario too - just a few
months of not managing the park well
enough so that's something that almost
happened here but aside from that now
that I've turned the situation around
I'm actually reaching the goals really
quickly so I'm not gonna have that much
time anymore to work on stuff in this
scenario so for one I plopped down a
staff building on next to the pond here
which is partly scenery I think it looks
quite nice to have it there but you also
just need one of these in each of your
parks and usually the youth scenario is
don't
with them is that something to keep in
mind and also a ferris wheel here over
the paths as I wanted to do just because
I think that gives you the best view of
the park both of the side with bumblebee
the flying coaster as well as the area
which I've just built in this episode
and it just gives me another excuse to
build some more scenery around it as
well so yeah that's that that's that
weird passage through the hills with the
ferris wheel on top of it which is a bit
unusual but I kind of liked it and aside
from that I'm just adding some foliage
everywhere because I added some pretty
detailed foliage with a lot of crunch
rubbery around the areas that I newly
built so I wanted to also put some of
that foliage in the older areas of the
park that I didn't build but that the
scenario already came with and my final
ride of this park is going to be a
spiral slide and yeah that is basically
it's three flat rides a log flume and a
coaster and aside from that it's really
just all down to management but that's
all it took for me to finish the
scenario so yeah really not too
difficult I do have to say and you might
have noticed this also on some of my
time lapses I got a lot of really bad
weather and I don't know whether I just
got unlucky with this or whether it's
actually a parameter that is supposed to
make this scenario more difficult but
it's definitely something that can rain
on your parade if you if you're trying
to hold the goals for two months because
as soon as it rains people are not gonna
write the coasters and you might not be
able to get 2,000 dollars in total
revenue for two months in a row but
thankfully it stayed sunny this whole
time the last few months so I was able
to reach these objectives and as you can
see we're almost there so let's take a
look at the park and see how it's doing
so I think I totally jinxed it by
talking about the rain because now it
started raining but to be honest it's
not really an issue because at this
point it's way too late anyway I'm gonna
reach these objectives and it should be
fine
so yeah the park is doing quite well
people are still riding the log flew
just because they are stuck in the queue
and now they're gonna have to ride it
anyway and the same goes for the coaster
so sometimes having these slightly
longer queues can definitely be handy to
try and cover the rainy periods as well
but yeah we're we're getting there and
there's really not too much else to show
off in the park anymore either I've got
the slide here and yeah that's basically
it and the first wheel here so there's a
bit of detailing and scenery around that
as well but aside from that I really
didn't build too much in this park as I
said five rides and a bunch of scenery I
did spend quite a bit of time trying to
make all of the rights interact as much
as possible with each other so for me
personally it did feel like more labor
than the usual just plopping down rights
or making quick coaster layouts but
that's also really fun as well like I
really like trying to make rides
interact with each other and working
with difficult terrain so as far as I
know some of the later scenarios are
definitely going to be more fun in that
regard as well but yeah altogether I
have to say this was quite an easy
scenario to be very honest despite the
fact that you have a lot of objectives
none of them are particularly hard and I
also have to say I made the map quite a
bit easier by giving you bumblebee right
from the start because this thing is
pretty profitable and efficient so yeah
that's definitely quite a helping hand
there but that said the terrain of the
the map did turn out to be quite
interesting to work with I have to admit
this is a scenario that I played through
earlier when I was making this scenario
I officially didn't do any beta testing
I wasn't supposed to do any testing but
for some of the scenarios I just played
through them entirely for fun basically
but also to kind of test how things were
going
what would be a good scenario or not and
this is one of them so this is actually
one of the scenarios I know best and
where I'm kind of familiar with the
terrain even more so than just any other
scenario that I've worked on so there's
that but to be fair I'm I did change
quite a few things about the terrain in
this playthrough as well so yeah I'm
pretty happy with it despite the fact
that it's quite minimalistic and simple
and it's not too much then I add it to
the park so yeah on that notes I'd like
to check out what the next map is going
to be because I honestly have no idea I
totally didn't save there but I know for
sure that I save just before reaching
the objective so that's fine and yeah we
got that little observation Hut's which
would be used for any park rangers or
whatever really the idea of this park
was to be somewhere in the national park
kind of setting so yeah we got that
plopped down as a trophy here and I
think the next one is going to be
coaster Canyon yeah that looks like it's
going to because the canyon yep that's
it alright so I never actually knew that
this was here on the map but this is
also one of the scenarios that I've
worked on and the terrain on the map
really looks just like the one in the
actual scenario so this one is going to
be very interesting I've actually heard
quite a few stories about this one I
usually like to check this subreddits
and other places to see how people are
doing in the scenarios and what some of
my favorite scenarios are what they did
is like and like about it so honestly
you can leave all of your constructive
criticism in the comments section as
well especially if you have negative
criticism because that's that's an
important lesson and maybe something
that could be changed about the
scenarios but yeah this is one that I've
read a lot about because it seems like
people like the fact that you have to
build a certain amount of coasters in
the park with a certain kind of
excitement rating in addition to getting
a certain amount of guests as well and
then the optional core on this one is
actually much more optional than all
those other goals so far because
yoshino girls they have 700 guests so if
you somehow get 700 guests with only 5
coasters
I suspect you get some kind of bonus
from that but I don't remember exactly
how all of that went either way for next
episode I'm gonna have to decide between
orchard acres and coaster Canyon and I'm
really not sure which one of these 2 I
would choose but that's something for
another day for now I'd like to thank
you guys for watching and I hope to see
guys in the next episode